[Musik]
[Applaus]
dort steht dann ein absturz
und die einsatzleitung hat gesagt jemand
ist an der nordwand abgestürzt
[Applaus]
es ist heute schon der dritte
bergsteiger der abgestürzt ist
ein guter tag zum klettern
schon spät oder die ski saison ist in
vollem gang zu wie auf der autobahn
zwischen zwei stunden ist das dunkel
ich sehe niemanden
da sind zwei aber die klettern nur
laut der koordinaten müsste es hier sein
aber da ist niemand
muss hier sein
ich sehe nichts vorliegt liegt anna
überall ausrüstungsteile
er muss gerutscht sein
er ist er rutscht man das unten durch
das mal den arzt rausgeht dass da wird
das geht ja
[Musik]
ich stieg aus
da jetzt schon
neu sei
[Musik]
weil ihre so haben wir einen leichensack
diashow
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn ich morgens aufwache und das
matterhorn durchs fenster sehe ist das
ein herrlicher tagesbeginn
[Musik]
ein majestätischer anblick
das matterhorn ist mein zuhause
ich kenne es durch die vielen
rettungsaktionen in und auswendig
[Musik]
schon als kind haben mich der berg und
seine schönheit fasziniert
meine familie hat eine lange klettert
radiation das war früher eine der
wenigen möglichkeiten mit denen man geld
verdienen konnte deshalb waren meine
großväter bergführer in der umgebung von
zermatt sie standen beide auf dem gipfel
des matterhorns mein vater hat es
ebenfalls bezwungen und ich auch
wenn man in einer gegend lebt in der
viele berge 4000 meter und höher sind
muss man einfach respekt vor ihnen haben
die meisten familien haben durchs
klettern ein oder zwei mitglieder
verloren
dadurch entwickelt man automatisch
respekt vor den sagen und der natur
[Musik]
für mich war es schon immer ein traum in
einer solchen umgebung fliegen zu dürfen
ich finde ich habe den besten beruf der
welt
[Musik]
er ist gerade fertig geworden wir müssen
den heli aber noch testen hoffentlich
ist alles in ordnung
angefangen habe ich bei der rca hat als
fensterputzer
ich habe mich schritt für schritt
hochgearbeitet vom fensterputzer zum
luftfahrzeug mechaniker
du musst noch den front schild anziehen
da hat irgendwann bekam ich die
gelegenheit zu fliegen und fluglehrer zu
werden
als ich schließlich die chance bekam
geschäftsführer der erzähler zu werden
stellte ich nur eine einzige bedingung
ich wollte auch weiterhin fliegen dürfen
[Musik]
das ist fantastisch in dieser gegend
hubschrauber zu fliegen
wir finden in 12 minuten ist man auf
einer höhe von dreieinhalb ist 4000
meter
die landschaft leuchte den herrlichen
farben
über die wolken und
es ist unbeschreiblich
einfach umwerfend in diesen bergen
aufzuwachsen und die rettungseinsätze zu
erleben
ich bin auf der ganzen welt geflogen
kommt einige male hatte ich sogar
rettungseinsätze im himalaya rundflug
auf 7000 meter höhe
er ist auf dem mount everest kommt ein
hubschrauber wegen des niedrigen
luftdrucks normalerweise gar nicht
es ist gut diese erfahrung gemacht zu
haben sein arbeitsgerät genau zu kennen
besonders in einem umfeld wie diesem
das ist wichtig fürs überleben
es fehlt mal auf der rechten seite die
fahrer
wisst ihr wie bedienen
potenzielle kunden
[Musik]
die besten der besten aus allen
möglichen sportarten kommen nach zermatt
wann immer ihr extrem skifahrer oder
paraglider in der nähe des matterhorns
seht achtet auf den hubschrauber der ist
von air zermatt
[Musik]
egal ob man extrem ski fährt oder einen
hubschrauber fliegt
man bewegt sich immer am rande seiner
fähigkeiten
da bleibt kein raum für fehler
das ist hier bei 73
korrekt
127,7
ich habe dicke finger
ist zu niedrig sie schon du hast dich
liebe diese band sein hobby gefunden
ein ähnlicher patient bei saas fee mit
promotion mit gehirnerschütterung
auch solche wo der patient ist zwischen
mourinho und felski verstanden wir
fliegen zum morinia
was haben wir
unglücklich ist skifahrer er ist
gestürzt und war bewusstlos was sie
vermutlich eine ernstere
kopfverletzungen
eine kopfverletzung sind immer
gefährlich
da muss man sofort reagieren
okay leute auf uns warten
windturbulenzen von etwa 25 bis 30
knoten
ich bleibe auf dieser seite bis wir den
pass hinter uns haben danach fliege ich
auf die andere seite rüber
[Musik]
es wird verflixt holprig werden
es ist alles gut
er wusste genau
was kostet eine chance sich im schauen
aber ich sehe
[Musik]
so jetzt leer werden dabei gewesen bei
dem unfall
wie lang kunst du mit ihm lesen
ich habe die augen
also bewusstlos werden
wenn der arzt wir schauen jetzt mal was
du hast und dann entscheiden wie es geht
ok
moritz dir hier will
geht oder merkst du merkst er holt kommt
mal hier an meiner seite bitte
danke geholt
wie alt ist
sie sind die mutter
moritz
kritischen schmerzmittel ließ
ich lass mal die kollegen arbeiten ja
reden mal grad
[Musik]
so wie das aussieht hat er erstens
schwere gehirnerschütterung und da es
immer möglich dass es auch eine blutung
gibt wenn das so lange bewusstlos war
man muss in eine klinik wo es in der
lage sind ein zentrum alles machen zu
können
ich gehe mit ihm in die uniklinik nach
bern
[Musik]
cottbus mit 1 2 aus
apa
[Musik]
wenn bei einem unfall kinder involviert
sind erhöht sich der druck gewaltig man
geht mit viel mehr emotionen an die
sache heran
alles klar bei
der euro
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
bei meinem job entscheide ich nicht über
leben und tod ich bin nur der pilot der
ausrüstung und medizinisches personal an
ihr ziel bringt den code
review
akzeptiert wenn man das akzeptiert hat
ist es viel leichter sich vollkommen
aufs fliegen zu konzentrieren
bitter
aber das lernt man mit der zeit je mehr
einsätze man hat
[Musik]
ja
wir sind weltmeister darin unsere
emotionen beiseite zu schieben
10 jähriger snowboarder über die
sprunghügel gelandet vermutlich mein
kopf und den rückenpartie
nachgewiesen 20 bis 30 minuten
bewusstlos gewesen sorgen
man vergisst die tragischen momente
nicht es ist eher so als würde man sie
in einer kiste versteckt
aber ab und zu kommen die erinnerungen
wieder hervor
davon darf man sich jedoch nicht
unterkriegen lassen
[Musik]
zermatt wurde gegründet weil unser tal
so oft durch lawinen und erdrutsche vom
rest der welt abgeschnitten war deshalb
brauchten wir unterstützung aus der luft
wir haben 65 mitarbeiter
doch die ärzte
bei lueg helfer
rettungssanitäter und natürlich die
chauffeure unsere piloten
ist einer der besten piloten
alles rund um den flugbetrieb unterliegt
seiner verantwortung
bei uns stimmt
wer ist äußerst präzise
[Musik]
manchmal benimmt er sich wie eine diva
tut mir leid
gold ist nur zehn jahre älter als ich
120 jahre älter aus wir sind nur zehn
einen spalten sturz
als junger kerl war ich ein
adrenalin-junkie
ich bin gefahren wie ein irrer war
basejumper und immer auf der jagd nach
gefährlichen situationen
doch als ich anfing für den such und
rettungsdienst zu fliegen musste ich
verantwortung für mich und andere
übernehmen
das hat mich auf den boden zurückgeholt
ich wusste ich muss mein leben ändern
sonst würde ich wohl nicht sehr alt
werden
wir piloten müssen konzentriert bleiben
das ist kein 08 15
wir haben rund 1700 einsätze pro jahr
in der hochsaison etwa 20 pro tag
als pilot fühlt man sich für sein team
verantwortlich
[Musik]
jeder fehler den du machst könnte dann
letzter sein
zumal die resonanz
ist es wert ist neutral gut für mich
das gefährlichste an meinem job ist in
den hubschrauber zu steigen
werden hätte der mensch fliegen
bräuchten wir keine hubschrauber
wir sind auf 1500 meter
tief liegt wirklich gut mal auf 4.500 m
travel mit maximaler leistung
kriegst du
wir fliegen in großer höhe zwischen den
bergen da ist die leistung eines
hubschraubers viel geringer als auf
meereshöhe
wir haben starken rückenwind auf dieser
seite bläst wird es unangenehm
es ist ein komplett anderes fliegen in
den wagen entstehen heftige winde
zusammen mit der schwächeren leistung
wird das fliegen dadurch ungleich
kniffliger
der heli ist in den bergen immer an
seiner leistungsgrenze du musst dir
selbst zutrauen dass du der
verantwortung für dein team gewachsen
ist
[Musik]
das sowie deshalb achten wir so sehr auf
sicherheit denn man weiß nie was
passiert
[Musik]
mit männlicher patient sturz auf der
piste schulterverletzung
robbie ist ein klasse pilot
ich denke das sind wir alle
[Musik]
aber robbie liebt es am limit zu viel
weil ein bisschen auch drin
[Musik]
jeder möchte fliegen
und jeder kann pilot werden aber nicht
jeder flieger ist auch ein adler obwohl
es gerne wäre
es macht einfach spaß an die grenzen zu
gehen
ist der patient irgendwo vor uns
er sollte er sein
[Applaus]
in einem großen skigebiet wie diesem
wenn es steil ist und wo sich viele
skifahrer aufhalten muss man abwägen ob
man landen kann ist es überhaupt möglich
ist es sicher genug ansonsten muss man
die seilwinde benutzen
und zum landen wir müssen
gut stehen unter
linde ist bereit
wenn du bereit wende läuft
huckepack los
[Musik]
weiter so noch etwa zehn meter
noch 4 3 2 1 meter position halten
wer lust hat doch geklappt er tadellos
[Musik]
weil meine schulter
das ist mein zwölftes logbuch
ersten september 1989 da war ich 22
damals habe ich noch aufgeschrieben was
bei den einsätzen alles passiert ist und
wo sie waren das mache ich jetzt nicht
mehr ich nummerieren sie nur noch
mein erster einsatz hat die nummer 30
jetzt bin ich bei fast 4400
ich komme auf 14.000 stunden an den
letzten 25 jahren
[Musik]
robert anpacken ist qualifiziert für
allein flüge in der us- 300 mario für
die partie an den erinnere ich nicht
[Musik]
ein zeitungsartikel den ich eingeklebt
habe
ein neunjähriger junge ist in einen see
gefallen seine körpertemperatur lag nur
noch bei 17 grad
das weiß ich noch
es war am 30 juli 1992
er ist beim spielen irgendwie
reingefallen und unter das eis geraten
die mussten erst mal finden und dann
rausholen furchtbare sache die mutter
war fertig aber er ist ohne einen
kratzer davon gekommen
ich erinnere mich daran als wäre es
gestern gewesen
[Musik]
ihr onkel meiner frau
erwies ohne ein bergführer er starb auf
dem matterhorn mit seinem
im august
ich habe seinen leichnam vom berg runter
geholt
unglaublich
sind eingehängten
kantone komme
bevor ich pilot wurde bergführer am
matterhorn
niemand hat das matterhorn so oft
bezwungen wie mein vater über 850 mal
ich selbst war vielleicht 70 mal oben
als ich klein war lag mein vater tote
vom matterhorn tote verletzte und
immer zu fuß es gab damals noch keine
hubschrauber
als zum ersten mal verletzte mit dem
hubschrauber vom berg geholt wurden war
ich überwältigt
diese piloten haben leben gerettet
definitiv was denke das war der grund
warum ich selbst rettungseinsätze mit
dem hubschrauber fliegen wollte
[Musik]
ich finde der nähe von zermatt
aufgewachsen
schon immer wollte ich zum
rettungsdienst
als kind war ich sehr beeindruckt davon
wie die hubschrauber den menschen
geholfen haben
wer in den bergen aufwuchs sowie wir
konnte beobachten wie die helis
lebensmittel brachten und sich um die
menschen kümmerten das wollte ich auch
tun diese leute waren helden für mich
als kind
ich bin 44 jahre alt und selbst pilot
[Musik]
man sollte nie hinterfragen warum jemand
in not gerät je mehr urlauber in die
berge kommen desto mehr unfälle gibt es
eben für uns ist das normal
[Musik]
in unserer fast 50-jährigen geschichte
haben wir unzählige kollegen freunde und
familienmitglieder verloren dennoch sind
wir der meinung dass jeder zugang zu
dieser wundervollen landschaft haben
sollte um seine träume zu verwirklichen
[Musik]
berlin
hinter den rettungseinsätzen steht der
gedanke dass es selbstverständlich ist
anderen menschen zu helfen
deshalb tun wir das
die schweizer berge sind die schönsten
der welt
aber so schön sie sind so viel gefahr
geht auch von ihnen aus
das matterhorn gehört zu den weltweit
gefährlichsten berge
ein guter freund von mir ist bergführer
der schlägt mir jedes jahr vor mit ihm
auf den gipfel zu klettern aber das
mache ich nicht
wenn ich hochfahren könnte ja warum
nicht in einem rennen war
ich bin geklettert bis sich etwa 20 war
jorge 20 hielt man sich für unverwundbar
aber das ändert sich wenn man erwachsen
wird
meine erfahrung sagt mir der mensch
sollte auf dem boden bleiben
wir sind auf dem weg zum fun park
beim anflug sieht man die patienten
normalerweise sitzen oder stehen aber
wenn sie auf dem rücken liegen weiß man
sofort das bedeutet nichts gutes
nach 23 minuten fange ich immer an über
ihr leben zu grübeln
14 oder stelle
szenen geboren 2005
wirklich so jung
kinder sind unschuldig wer in
kinderaugen sieht und nicht davon
berührt ist es kein mensch
[Applaus]
und wir fliegen nach 14 jährige patient
möglicherweise rückenverletzung
jetzt alles gut da hinten
[Musik]
er hatte mit helikopter wir nehmen uns
von 7 auf 1700 meter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
alles gut
müde nein gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zum ende weiter auseinander
nun junior weiter auseinander
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was ist los ich habe zweimal daneben
getroffen einmal ganz knapp
musste besser ziehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mais an mein sohn las in der zeitung
über einen piloten der auf der nordseite
der schweizer alpen abgestürzt ist
er fragte mich ob ich ihn kenne ich
sagte ja
und ist er fragte papa warum fliegst du
danach
bin ich antwortete ihm wenn du dich
entscheidest rettungs pilot so werden
dann tust du das aus leidenschaft
weil du menschen helfen willst weil du
es gerne tust
mein sohn ist mir sehr ähnlich er meinte
ja du hast recht und somit war das thema
verinnerlicht
[Musik]
er ist tot
haben wir einen leichensack
ja natürlich
[Musik]
nicht porsche und später oder
es ist heikel hier nach sonnenuntergang
zu fliegen
und wir sagen der polizei wir hätten
keine wahl gehabt wir mussten die leiche
mit
[Musik]
wir hoffen
du kannst uns abholen
[Musik]
der täter
ja nicht ganz so weit links
[Musik]
für heute habe ich genug gesehen
jetzt legen wir heim
[Musik]
je länger man als pilot arbeitet desto
mehr erkennt man dass das was man tut
nicht normal ist
denn man schwebt ständig zwischen himmel
und erde
[Musik]
ich bin sehr glücklich mit meinem job
es ist ein gutes gefühl leben zu retten
aber
es herrscht immer das jenjahn prinzip
[Musik]
[Applaus]
manche haben glück
andere weniger
so ist es eben
[Musik]
durch die tätigkeit meines vaters war
mir der tod vertraut
ich habe gesehen wie freunde auf dem
berg gestorben sind
ich wurde rettungs pilot um menschen zu
helfen und
zwar so dass ich dabei leben retten
das bedeutet mir alles
wir haben keinen direkten einfluss auf
leben und tod
das ist etwas das wir akzeptieren müssen
das begreift man aber erst wenn man
schon unzählige jahre geflogen ist
wenn man jemandem hilft ist es das
großartigste gefühl das es gibt die
größte befriedigung die ein rettungs
pilot erhalten kann wir waren sieben
oder acht jahre als wir herkamen in der
hoffnung dass die ingenieure uns nicht
entdeckten schlichen wir uns langsam an
den hubschrauber heran
plötzlich stehen sie uns an und wir
rannten weg aber zehn minuten später
waren wir wieder da
[Musik]
schon als kind wusste ich was mein
traumberuf
hubschrauberpilot
wenn man in einer landschaft wie dieser
fliegen kann ich bin froh dass ich mein
traum erfüllt hat es ist der beste beruf
der welt was will man mehr
[Musik]